Welcome back everyone this will be my full house
of the dragon episode 2 video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'm
doing videos for all the episodes just like i did
for the main series and we're doing a giveaway
for hbo max subscriptions all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just post your
favorite moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments starting
with the brand new title scene so probably one
of the biggest surprises biggest wtf moments
was the cool intro scene that they did like it
looks almost like the original series with the
miniature obviously meant to look very different
for this series but they used the exact same game
of thrones theme music i'm so surprised that they
actually didn't switch up the actual theme song
i'm also wondering now if they're gonna change
this new intro each episode based on the events
of the episodes just like they did on the original
series like in each game of thrones episode they
would change the map that they focused on
just based on where you went in each episode
but the other major difference in this intro
if you couldn't tell is that it's meant to be
a metaphorical and literal targaryen family tree
like it's meant to show the targaryens literally
and metaphorically being the blood of old valyria
that's why it's blood flowing down from the
ancient valyrian freehold the actual model is of
the ancient valyrian freehold itself it's the same
model that you see king viserys building in his
bed chambers here the reason why it's black is
because of the black rock that it was built from
inside the mouth of a volcano that's why dragon
stone is black too like it looked kind of like
the same rock that the dragonstone was made of
that'll remind you of all the dragonglass that's
on dragonstone that would have also been in the
ancient valyrian freehold which is critical for
fighting white walkers in the night king a little
bit of a backdoor song of ice and fire long night
reference there too but you see the blood flowing
through all the different symbols it's meant to
show the bloodline of their family and all the
different symbols represent the different members
of their household down to present day ending in
rhaenyra's symbol those are the people represented
in the family tree here because they marry into
the family and become part of their bloodline or
they're like the velaryons and they are also the
blood of ancient valyria so they're represented in
the map too like you see some of the symbols like
way off in the background and some of them are in
the forefront the ones in the forefront are all
the targaryens so starting with the path at the
top and the cymbals this is what they all mean
it starts with a symbol of the doom of valyria
like you see the actual freehold symbol itself as
the blood flows up that's meant to represent the
doom itself like the volcano literally erupting
in destroying ancient valyria technically it was
the 14 flames 14 volcanoes all in a chain right
next to each other all going off simultaneously
suddenly it seems like a bad idea to build your
freehold inside the mouth of a volcano but then
the next path is the picture here it shows aegon's
conquest the war of conquest in the background
then it shows aegon the conqueror's crown after
the conquest next it has two symbols and they're
for visenya and rhaenys aegon's sister wives then
i believe the next one was aenys he was one of
the next kings after aegon like it shows the path
of kings in the targaryen family then the next
one are jaeharys and his wife alyssane targaryen
and you notice how the blood flows out of the
cymbals that's meant to represent them both being
targaryens in their blood co-mingling like them
sister wiving and the reason why there are all
these paths of blood that split out from them are
because they had many many children the next ones
i believe are for balon and alyssa targaryen
two of his children baelon was viserys's father
then because we moved to baelon's children you
see daemon's line split off on the other side
you see viserys's symbol and then his first wife
aemma arryn you see how the blood sort of connects
her sigil house arryn sigil to the targaryen
sigil because she was a targaryen through her
mother's side so she was also part of the family
already in the background i believe this is meant
to be for rhaenys the queen who never was in corls
velaryon she's metaphorically kind of removed from
the action after viserys is named king during
the great council so i think literally on the
map here that's why they put her symbol way in the
background then when the path turns into a raging
river it's meant to signify the proliferation
of targaryens like there are many many of them
on both the targaryen side and the velaryon side
all the blood of ancient valyria in the last
big symbol here you should recognize is ronira's
valyrian necklace that was given to her by daemon
the symbol on the wall above here is just meant
to represent the dance of the dragon's war
then as it zooms out on the entire model you just
see a metaphorical and little representation of
how their family tree is the blood of ancient
valyria is a very cool way to depict a family
tree obviously with the design behind the title
being similar but a little bit different from
the astro labe that they use for the original
title the astro labe in the original game of
thrones intro scene is the one that you see in
the maester citadel this time the symbol that
they end on is the targaryen household symbol but
is in the mouth of a volcano the reason why it's
a volcano though is because viserys explains to
alicent the ancient valyrian freehold was built
inside the mouth of a volcano in the 14 flames
so that they could be closest to the source of
the dragon's power because dragons lived in that
area naturally they crave warmth living there was
necessary for them to hatch their young you also
notice the inaugurion that he talks about where
the blood mages practice their dark arts and
created dragon bonding just in general probably
used blood magic to literally bond the blood of
dragons to the higher born valyrian dragon lords
was the inspiration for the targaryens when they
built dragonstone like dragonstone is meant to be
a replica of the ancient valyrian freehold in the
inaugurion here there are a lot of theories about
what happened in ancient valeria and why
targaryens the other dragonlords in particular
are bonded to dragons but not the lesser
houses of the freehold like the velaryons.
The title of the episode is the rogue prince which
is what the realm calls daemon targaryen because
he's metaphorically the rogue prince like he's not
really good about following the rules as you see
in this episode where he literally steals a dragon
egg to try and create some attention for himself
the rogue prince is also the title of one
of the short stories that makes up the book
fire and blood the history of the targaryen
family but the actual opening scene is of
crab feeder and his army in the stepstones paying
off that scene where corlys velaryon explains why
he's called crab feeder his real name is cragas
drahar but he ties up his victims in low tide
and literally feeds them to the crabs when the
high tide comes in like you see all these crabs
crawling around here eating people we get a real
quick shot of crabfeeder at the end of the episode
he's the one with the horribly burnt face in the
mask you saw him in the trailer a couple times too
and because during the reveal on his face their
inner cutting cordless talking about the second
sons the idea of being the lesser members of great
dynasties of families not only is that meant to be
an easter egg for the second sons the mercenary
company in essos in game of thrones later in the
timeline now i'm also kind of wondering if crab
feeder is secretly a member of the targaryen
family like a targaryen bastard or just somebody
who was way lower in the line of succession and
was either exiled or just forgotten about or just
cast off in a song of ice and fire too a lot of
the mercenary companies in the east like the
golden company later in the timeline they didn't
get created till after the blackfyre rebellions
but a lot of these mercenary companies were
comprised of westerosi bastards and exiled nobles
so the same could be true for crab feeder but when
they pick back up in the small council meeting we
find out it's been a year since the end of episode
one so that gives you an idea for how quickly
they're jumping through the timeline there'll be
bigger time jumps in later episodes though they're
talking about replacing the former lord commander
of the kingsguard ryan redwine he was this old
guy in episode one you saw standing around in
the background they said that he just died after
a long illness after the events of episode one and
harold westerling played by graham mctavish here
is just taking over as the new lord's commander
but they have to replace the empty position on the
kingsguard because there needs to be seven for the
seven different kingdoms which rhaenyra winds up
filling with criston cole even though she has a
crush on him she is right when she says that he is
the only member of the group here who has actual
combat experience but you do notice when they're
selecting the next member of the kingsguard you
do see a lot of members of houses that we didn't
see during the main show like there are many many
lesser houses in the song of ice and fire most
the time on game of thrones you really only meet
the great houses so because this is a totally
different show they try to feature other houses
as much as possible but also during this period
of the timeline a lot of different houses were
also much more active and central to the story
than were during the events of game of thrones
you notice the shot of them pouring the wine into
the cup that's also meant to be a metaphor for the
targaryen bloodline because one of the main
topics of the episode is viserys remarrying
and having more heirs along with daemon targaryen
separately talking about having more heirs himself
cordless velaryon scene here just meant to set up
his alliance that he forms with daemon at the end
of the episode because the king won't take any
action and seems like he doesn't care that much
about what's happening to corliss or the potential
threat to his business even though he is meant
to be a weak king patty considine says that
viserys feels like this great weight coming out
of jiharis's reign because so much of jaeharys'
reign was this time of prosperity for the realm
he's trying to keep the good times rolling so to
speak as much as possible like avoid conflict as
much as possible but like later in the episode
where corliss talks to him about this metaphor
of steering into or going around a storm never
waiting for it that's also meant to show you
how viserys's inaction like his inability to make
hard choices helps lead to the events of the dance
of the dragons like him not heeding corliss's
advice is really bad and eventually causes this
giant targaryen civil war renera getting thrown
under the bus by the small council is just meant
to dovetail with the conversation that she then
has with rainey's later when she's like how do you
think it's gonna be i mean get real with yourself
there's no way they're gonna let you be queen
trying to tell her that the realm isn't going
to take her seriously no matter what she does
so when she takes matters into her own hands
later in the episode and goes after daemon and the
dragon egg on her own like pulling in arya kind
of that's just meant to show you more context for
the way that she reacts to this kind of situation
like she's not going to take things lying down she
doesn't want to be another queen who never was
she's meant to be a little bit more like daemon
even viserys says that like oh you remind me my
brother when we were much younger i've forgotten
about it but she's not quite as chaotic as daemon
like she doesn't want to stir the pot quite as
much on purpose the way that he does there is a
lot of tension brewing between corlys velaryon
and otto hightower now he doesn't hate corliss but
he also doesn't really care about him that much
other than just expecting him to do whatever the
king asks of him like you're useful only as long
as you have your navy that's all we really care
about we don't really care about your business and
because of what happens later in the episode too
with the succession with the king marrying alicent
hightower instead of his daughter laena that just
meant to show you more of why he'd have a grudge
against house hightower in general when they say
daemon seized dragonstone in the past year that's
pretty much what happened in the books he was
ordered by the king to go back to runestone in
the vale and be with his wife ria royce and just
be quiet but he said hell no to that he took some
of the gold cloaks because he was the commander of
the city watch like he trained them as his dogs of
war basically and the reason why the king hasn't
really done anything about it like they say that
the crown has been quiet about it for the past
half year is because as daemon's brother viserys
knows exactly what's going on like oh he just
wants attention he's just trying to create a bunch
of noise he's not actually going to do anything
really crazy which you later find out is actually
kind of true like that was actually a pretty
good call on viserys's part just to ignore him
you notice when the dragon keeper comes to give
daemon's message to the king he speaks exclusively
in high valyrian because as a dragon keeper like
their lives are entirely dedicated to raising and
tending the dragons so they wouldn't speak in
anything but high valyrian because that's the
language the dragons understand so they explained
daemon stole a dragon egg and intended to give it
to his bastard that mysterio was pregnant with he
intended to marry her per the customs of ancient
valeria take a second wife so that the son would
not be born a bastard but like after he gives the
dragon egg back and merceri gets really pissed
off at him she's like what you announced were
gonna get married as if she didn't know that
they were planning on getting married like what
and she tells them she would never want to have
a child like i'm never gonna threaten myself with
childbirth so basically daemon was lying about
most of that stuff and doing a lot of this just
for attention you also notice the scene where
rhaenyra comes to bargain with him and get the
dragon egg back without the show of force when
they're talking to each other in high valyrian she
just like oh you've come and taken my home because
i'm the princess of dragonstone i'm the heir the
heir is always named the prince or princess
of dragonstone so technically dragonstone does
belong to her any kind of jokes about eventually
getting married and having heirs that's just meant
to foreshadow a lot of their growing relationship
like there's this weird chemistry between them but
they're not in an actual relationship right now
so a lot of this dialogue is meant to be loaded
and foreshadowed the future of what will happen
between the two of them love the scene of viserys
explaining ancient valyria to alicent the freehold
here the model it was built to be a perfect
replica so like all the buildings and sizes are
appropriate along with the scale model of blaring
the black dread perched on one of the buildings
that's how big he was compared to the rest of
the buildings in the ancient valyrian freehold
so when he's talking about balerion being like
the last remaining living thing to have memories
from before the doom of valyria. Balerion wasn't
the only dragon that aenar targaryen took with the
family when they moved to dragonstone to escape
the doom but he's the only dragon from valeria
that survived after the move so both vhagar and
meraxes aegon's sister-wise dragons were born on
dragonstone after the move and now in present day
veigar is the oldest and biggest living dragon
as they explained during the episode i'll talk
about veigar in a second too because like a big
part of the episode is dedicated to talking about
vegar specifically the reason why viserys is so
particular about bullying the black dread himself
is because he was his final writer but he only
rode him once before Balerion died of natural
causes around the age of 200 dragons don't really
have a size limit so the older they get the bigger
they get which is why vhagar the oldest is also
the biggest dragon it's also why they joke that
vhagar is too big to actually nest inside the
dragon pit which is why they're allowing her to
roam free we see her a little bit in the trailers
like this is vegar we get a quick history lesson
on the culture of ancient valeria and how their
hierarchy worked inside the freehold the capital
was inside one of the actual 14 flames volcanoes
turns out bad call like i said putting your
capital in an active volcano there was no one
king ruling everyone in ancient valeria it was
just a group of the dragon lords all sitting on
a council together the dragonlords were the great
houses the ones who did all the dragon bonding
so they were the ones that owned all the dragons
but as corliss velaryon explains there were also
lesser families in ancient valeria who were not
bonded to dragons didn't carry the gene that's why
they have the white hair but the only members in
his family who can ride dragons are the ones who
are born of mixed marriages with targaryens like
rhaenys is a targaryen she married corlys velaryon
so their daughters and sons can ride dragons
as viserys says at its height the valyrian
freehold had thousands of dragons and the other
cool thing is that corlys velaryon reveals that
the velaryons are actually an older house than the
targaryens even though they weren't dragon riders
but because they didn't have dragons they turned
to sea trade to earn their money and the velaryons
actually came to westeros and driftmark long
before the targaryens came to dragonstone maybe at
some point we'll get another prequel series set in
ancient valyria that would be pretty cool i've
already talked a little bit about the inaugural
on here in my theory about how the blood mages
in valyria created the practice of dragonbonding
by using their magic to literally bond the
dragonlord's dna with the dragons themselves
so when new dragons were born they would sense
the other dragonlord families as one of their own
you get a couple quick moments here with
alicent and viserys just to let you know
what their relationship has kind of turned into in
the past here you also kind of sense what's going
on with her father in the background too like he
definitely knows at this point what he's doing
because there's all these conversations that he
has with him later about what do you think about
me getting married to lena valerio and he's like
you know you should think about that a little bit
and then later he tells his daughter oh by the
way you're gonna go see him tonight aren't you
you have to imagine that he's doing that with her
all the time like oh by the way you're gonna go
see him again aren't you again and again and again
and speaking of viserys current condition how can
we not talk about all the maggots like clearly he
is getting worse and worse and worse like the last
time we saw him he had a wound on his back that
wouldn't heal didn't seem that big but it seemed
like an ill-important of things to come now he's
starting to lose some of the digits on his hand
so if it's this bad now you wonder how bad he's
going to be in a couple more years after another
couple time jumps i've always thought of him as
like the sean bean ned stark type of character
during the series like really good person but
someone who just destined to meet an untimely end
we visit the great set for the first time on the
show and the figure that they're pranked to hear
is the maiden because of the big betrayal at the
end of the episode between rhaenyra and alicent
a lot of you have asked if they were actually in a
relationship like are they in love or what's going
on between the two of them i think it's possible
that they maybe had a little something on the dl
together but obviously at the end of this episode
that's all over like there's a big rift between
the two of them now because she treats it like a
big betrayal and the way she looks at her father
she also takes it as a betrayal from him as well
just kind of showing you the growing rift between
those two women between the blacks and the greens
as they eventually spin up into the dance of the
dragons way later in the timeline like how did
they go from being best of friends to being
bitter enemies this is like the next step on that
slippery slope then we see driftmark for the first
time ever i think i don't think they featured
it during the game of thrones series their main
castle here is called high tide we see a little
bit of the interior at the end of the episode but
we'll probably see more of it later episodes
i loved all rainy's targaryen scenes here her
speaking so frankly to both viserys and ranira
she tries to get real with both of them because
viserys is kind of ineffectual and unwilling to
make decisions so she's like you need to continue
the line of the targaryens the dynasty can't end
with you you just have to remember that viserys
is only supposed to be about 36 years old when
this is happening when he remarries to alicent
even though paddy considine is in his late
40s looks way older you have to imagine life
expectancy during that period wasn't that long
so technically he'd be considered an older man
but like for example alicent hightower is in her
mid-20s when she remarries to him so there's only
about nine or ten years between the two of them
then even though this idea of the marriage between
the two of them doesn't go anywhere laina velaryon
herself is a big character in the story at least
in this early part of the story there'll be a
couple time jumps during the series we'll meet
an older version of her character and the dragon
that she winds up writing i'll wait to talk about
that till we actually see it happen in some of the
episodes we'll probably get that in either episode
three or episode four i don't know how many it'll
be but for example there's a reason why she spent
that entire conversation with him talking about
veigar and i think one of the important scenes
during this that tells you how some of the
book information about these events is actually
misconstrued by the maesters is this whole event
that takes place at dragonstone the way they
wrote it in the books they make it sound like
it actually was true like mysterio was pregnant
with his bastard and eventually miscarried so if
you read the books what happens on the show is a
little bit different but what happens on the show
based on what george r martin is telling us is the
more truer version of events than what's written
down in the books because of the way the maesters
wrote everything down based on second and third
hand accounts of the events that happened during
this period so everyone across history has always
wondered what is the most correct version of that
story that's basically what they're aiming to do
with the house of the dragon episodes throughout
the whole dance of the dragons throughout the
entire series so that's why on the show it seems
like daemon was lying about having a bastard and
just doing this all for attention like he even
threw the dragon egg back at ranira like it was no
big deal so they'll probably do something similar
with future wtf events where like the people who
chronicled the books like the maesters who wrote
the books got history wrong viserys says that
he plans on marrying alicent soon in the spring
that's probably going to be like the next episode
if we jumped an entire year in the past episode
and then obviously they end the episode with
corlys velaryon taking matters into his own
hands forming the alliance with daemon to destroy
crab feeder in the triarchy's army starting what
will be the war of the stepstones that sounds
like it's gonna be either one or two episodes
and they'll start in episode three next week the
actual war lasted for several years but they might
just compress that because of all the time jumps
in these first couple of episodes and like i said
his conversation with daemon at the end about
second sons and seizing glory for themselves
in showing you crab feeder's face just makes it
sound like crab feeder is more closely related to
some of these people than we believe like he's
secretly a member of the family distantly too
but post all your theories in the comments
below like what do you think is actually going
on with craft feed or potentially being
a second son of a really highborn person
if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the video write
them below in the comments my episode 3 trailer
video will post next in my full episode 3 video
we'll post next week after they release it i do
have a couple big bonus videos planned for this
week too we could talk all day about what happened
in ancient valeria it's just so interesting
everyone click here for my house of the dragon
episode 3 video i'll update the link as soon
as i post that and click here for my house of the
dragon season 2 announcement in top 10 predictions
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!